you don't mess with you se retrouvent
sur chivalry deadliest warrior parce que
c'est vraiment un jeu que j'adore je
sais que je déjà fois plus aujourd'hui
je me suis levé je me suis dit et si on
coupait des bras et des jambes hâlées
c'est bizarre duel engagé au plat dans
le bouclier pas c'est bien ça vient
bientôt porter testicules un talent air
musclé ok je m'en vais je veux moi j'en
ai pas moi j'ai vu que tu es busqué déjà
attention aux voilà il m'a défoncé passe
par le haut niveau ni connu c'est
tellement bien dans les deux tours en
toi comme ça je me sens vraiment viril
rockets - dieu non c'est pas aux merde
merde merde à temps mais il est trop
rapide quoi je prends au courant et d'où
il a une fois il vient deschamps cet
homme steve est non c'est adoptent à
leur base il ya là où ce nom de v1
allait mourir
mais l'ex affola ça suffit ça suffit il
faut pas commencer leur âge et c'est
bien bas vient de battre bonjour c'est
bon ils sont en train de se battre et
lâchant mon art comme ça au maintenant
metex un [ __ ] de le regarder mais
regardez-moi ça fait quoi je veux dire
tiens un gros coup d'épée siens dragons
qui leurs deux mots qu balle et sa mère
vous avez vu il a dit oh [ __ ] de sa
mère quand il jouait ninja bah tu sais
quoi je jouais ninja obama a regardé
c'était ça son arme le tout niveau 3 la
salle est le truc où il faut cent
soixante dix heures de jeu pour la voir
oui je craque obtient laisser mon ami
tranquille
ok j'en ai eu un je me tire aux mondiaux
vous avez entendu un hidjab ou suis
piquée dit maintenant mesdames on est en
plein de mai du mois je fais jamais ça
tu vois donc tu es vraiment pas bon ok
jacques j'appuie sur une touche et me
dit de me taire quoi le perso
et dans cette faute personne ne suivait
pas et bien là et bien là moi je suis
pour me suis comme toi voilà je suis pom
parce que des versions brochettes
je n'ai touché à un mollet bientôt voilà
vous avez quoi on va retourner sur le
chiva lri normal c'est parti
attends chez toi en fait si tu as encore
ou quoi s'attache pas quand tu quelqu'un
alors suivant je vous attends moi
hachette court quand le cac ont foutu et
lui mais non j'ai coupé la tête un pote
[ __ ] elle cette catastrophe
aujourd'hui la malédiction ils sont
touchés en allié au merde ils sont tous
sur moi maintenant est ce que vous
m'avez jamais les garages
alors je suis un dj à moi on est plutôt
dédié ce warrior méchante [ __ ] de
ninja question objectifs suivants
protéger des villageois ok ya un mode
est tout petit je connais pas du tout je
répétais la tête en bas bon à savoir il
avait deux têtes le 20 août est un peu
plus enfoncée dans la nuque tu fais quoi
toi protégeant les villageois et il faut
pas qu'il ya cette porte est faux pas
qui me casse pas non plus en fait vous
me direz on earth ampute un adieu radio
il va arriver là j'ai pu être abondé je
fais quoi chaunu je saute à l'eau louons
120 qui cède
ok donc la loi doit en fait il peut on
peut se couper les bras les jambes et ou
à la violence
allez on va se faire lui on a terminé
bien là ma couille allait bien là
kouyias bien
voilà allez maintenant but j'adore ce
boîtier génial ou une tête de soldats
qu'ils ont mesdames et les couper la
tête à tout péter complètement cours où
l'attend monsieur tapie tu es tu vas
calvet déjà à temps mais tu fais quoi
t'es vu quand t'as bu six mois là-bas
temps coupé t il avec plus tard il était
vu comme un petit canard on fait une
remontée fulgurante qui l'a vous sortez
le skill qui nous envahit comme ça non
mais vous êtes 2 contre chaque fois non
hachette trouver le mec qui laisse à
martha tout ce qu'ils ont pu couper l'on
coupé pour rien de moi ça c'est un
scandale et y commence tu as tu vas te
calmer h f dans ta gueule
voila voila salut à bientôt oh mon dieu
à trop n'a plus rien adieu à tout va
bien mais ce qui les attend mais illégal
et injuste poney vous faute et un mois
et calmez vous s'il vous plaît encore au
liban
tu es tu mets chauds faut pas qu'ils
tuent les paysans faut pas qu'ils tuent
les paysans bande de bâtards il reste la
moitié des paysans bonjour vous êtes nul
tu te bats ou quoi alors je te tue c'est
indigne et chico se montrait bien
ridicule salut archers je pense pas
qu'un couteau pouvait te te fais pas la
tête chez taj la victime à décéder
je ris plus que je le pleure ô sa
j'adore
oh oui oh
l'année français moyen aïe si je peux
encore l'utiliser même avec un seul bras
plus maintenant jouer à la rareté sur de
toi jackson tac merde j'ai mis dans les
coups de bottes ou la toucher il faut
défendre le roi et où le roi j'aimerais
bien voir à quoi ressemble le roi à mon
dieu les lacets lui c'est le roi n'a
jamais vu ça il va décéder ta [ __ ] est
le toit faire biatch le che volet des
aventures respect au nom du roi est
décédé pillon sur la tête de l'union
s'il te plaît sur la tête du lion ce
n'est pas possible très bien eh ben je
décède alors allumé le feu de signal
pour avertir les bateaux j'envoie une
flèche d'éclaireurs voilà où la toucher
à l'état gueule attendez les gars légal
il ya il faut un marché de qualité comme
ça voilà bien du lot allez les gars à
temps je donne un petit ordre en avant
voilà vous avez compris je suis très bon
capitaine moi j'adore vraiment géré
vitres ou pas mais étend ce mec il a
tellement de bord mais encore mais c'est
pas vrai hop là voilà maintenant qu'il
est mort n'est pas tout si je peux le
disais
lui a transpercé la tête avec une flèche
à les morts adieu à les maths en battant
je te dis aux feux ont déboulé canal
nous pasqua la hâte en mai mais je suis
avec toi tu es comme toi mais tu es qu
aux morts où je bois ce qui t'empêche
mollahs mais si je tendais toute la
jetant des trucs mais ça a l'air de
marcher non by tourner monter sur un
fait peur on sait pas mais quand je
soutiens je me gratte les selles et ce
qui tient bien ses nouveaux quitte à
tuer c'est nous c'est lui tient est qu
adam mérite d'être jetés du haut
viens avec moi bon d'être dépassé je
serai programme mois l'agencé tap 1,7 et
2 sur steam et des malouins faille et un
peu de dédier ce warrior bon ça dure une
minute le temps qu'on se complète est 26
fois j'ai des choses à + 6 et 15 octobre
d'habitude la prochaine fois je suis
nouveau sur ce je bois sera dans
quelques mois et j'essaierai d'avoir
beaucoup de style pour faire des trucs
assez joli parce que là finalement c'est
bon les avis sont partagés sur le sujet
voilà baisse alors il ya des mesures
d'entraidé deux nouvelles vidéos du tout
le monde pis
[Musique]
à